hello everyone and welcome back to the
world Fisher random championship is Game
two of the rapid now Khurana has the
white pieces and after all that
craziness in the first round of the
rapids that ended in a draw we are now
treated to even even more of a crazy
game so without further ado let's just
check it out the game basically just
ended so I thought when I draw it while
I'm waiting for the next game to start
so Corona with the white pieces opens
with g3 which of course makes sense as
the bishops are on h1 and a1 you wanna
play g3 b3 and open up those those
bishops so cause and replies with the d5
grabbing the center we have b3 now
opening up the other bishop as well you
don't even have to feel in care of them
they are already on perfect perfect
squares with east six and now Queen to
h3 already developing the queen with g5
by Magnus and now Bishop captures on h8
rook captures now our black will not be
able to Castle kingside but Carson is
not planning to cast King said and to me
this looks something like something that
was either considered already while the
previous game was played or by by their
seconds as it just seems like a very
nice idea with castles by Caruana
and now h5 so here yeah we already have
a case of g4 and h4 on the board where
as Bobby has Castle King and g1 so looks
looks a bit too dangerous but okay c4 by
Fabi with beef or the magnets that a
Magnus wants to attack on the kingside
he doesn't want to open up the center or
the Queen side for that matter with III
and Knight the c6 are continuing
development knife to e2 and now d3 so
it's already a pawn on d3 if white will
not be able to attack it then it's gonna
be a great pawn if white will be able to
attack it and it's just gonna be a
liability for the rest of the game with
Knight eat the c3 and now comes Knight
8e 7 we have nice to e4 now and here
Magnus develops the Queen Queen to h6
now getting ready to push well either g4
or h4 depending on what Fabi plays 5
because for F 4 and the Magnus says we
are not going to open up the position
here he plays g4 and he says
we are going to open up the position
after I push a h4 Queen back to g2 and
now h4 with Nightbeat the c3 and here we
have castles Queen side also possible
was nice the f5 and v6 you do want to
open up this diagonal as soon as
possible since White's queen is still on
g2 but you're crossing takes this
opportunity to the Castle queenside and
now Knight to g5 threatening Knight
captures f7 which will be a very nice
fork so rugby to f8 defending f7 and now
B for Fabi gives up upon 2 O to make his
attacking on the Queen side happens just
a little bit faster yeah so Magnus
decides to capture it but first he wants
to open up the H file so H captures on
g3 we have h captors and g2 end only now
Knight captures on b4 rook the b1 now
that the B file is is semi open Knight
be back to c6 and now Kings to f2
getting the King away from that h2
square so if the Queen also enjoying the
attack maybe maybe you can double up
here maybe get this rope over here
recover here get the King as far away as
you can from the King side and here
Magnus goes for f5 but again also
possible was Knight to f5 followed by b6
as you definitely want to play b6 at
some point you don't want to all our
white double of rooks here for example
Queen to g1 you know that this diagonal
is going to open up so you could play
Queen g1 b6 now and now push up the e4
but here black has the the very pleasant
Queen H to check and after this trade
captures captures King goes back
kingi one group will capture on D to
defend the d3 point and now it's a it's
actually a very dangerous pawn now but
ok Carlson's idea is different he wants
to play more of a you know boa
constrictor style with f5 and the now
rook to b3 Fabi
continues his plan on the Queen said he
wants to double rooks here he 5 by
Magnus and now Knight to d5 we have E
for now and here Fabi has to decide what
to do here his position here is really
cramped he doesn't really have a lot to
do the Queen and Bishop really are not
getting out of here so it's a really
passive position and he's down on the
clock he he he has to
Magnus is around four minutes and here
Fabi play tonight captures on e4 he
sacrificed a pista to unwind here a bit
he doesn't like knife characters with
Czech captures and then just doubling up
here as after Queen 286 your position is
very passive like we said here queen is
gonna capture on c4 and you are not
actually doing anything with those
double drugs on the B file the b7 point
is nicely protected so it's not a
problem
so after this efore move Fabi decides to
capture at night capture sunny for F
captures and now Queen captures on e4 so
the queen is now released from the
prison but allows queen to h2 with check
you cannot go to e1 if if King do you
wanna just Quinta e 2 will be made so
you have to block Bishop to g2 and now
Knight to f5 so what do you do here
Queen captures and g3 is coming there's
not much you can do about that so Queen
to East 6th check by Fabi and now King
to DA if you could go to be it in the
screen captures on c6 is a is not very
pleasant for black so after queen te vi
checking to d8 not allowing such ideas
and then now rook captures on d3
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries after this Knight moves but
Queen captures on g3 with check King to
g1 and now Knight C to D for a cross and
gives back the piece to close off the D
file so here Fabi has to decide whether
he captures with he captures on d4 and
allows Queen h2 checking if to g3 with
check King you want and rook rook e8
just wins the Queen so this would be
winning for black so Bobby decides for
rook captures on d4 and now we have
Queen to h2 with check King to f2 and
now Queen to h4 with check King back to
g1 and only now capturing the roof so
Knight captures on d4 we have ecad force
on d4 and now finally b6 opening up this
light square bishop here so you don't
have any checks here the queen is nicely
controlling the e7 square otherwise you
would have 27 check followed by queen
says c7 checkmate so Queen to e5 now
Fabi goes for Queen captures on c7 but
rook to h7 Magnus defends it and here
Phi B pushes f5 here this
clock is Fabi 45 seconds Magnus two
minutes so g3 Magnus threatens made in
one with Quint h2 made so rook to e1
making some room for the king but now
rook h2 f7 there's always time to go for
this check so first the rock edge to f7
preparing to capture here we have rook
to e4 attacking Carlson's Queen but now
Queen to h2 with check King to f1 and
here rook captures on f5 attacking the
Queen and the king Luke the f4 by Fabi
and here
Magnus just played not rook captures
Queen which would allow rook captures
rook
Magnus just played rook captures rook
this comes with check and it was in this
position that
Fabiana Khurana resigned the game point
being that there is nothing you can do
here either you accept the roof for
example Knight captures and then you get
Queen captures in g2 as the knight
cannot capture the rook pins denied so
after the King moves and now you get
Queen if to check King to d1 and just
Queen captures on f4 and you are up a
bit up and the rook black has Oh white
has no moves here and if you don't
capture rook captures an f4 check if you
move the King King you want then you run
into rook f1 check very nicely done
Bishop captures rook captures with check
King captures and now Queen to f2 will
be made so it seems that Carson Carson
does have the upper hand when it comes
to rapid chess but we'll see anything
can still happen as it always can in
chess but I believe with the points
being as they are if Magnus I believe
wins one more game and then that's
enough for him to finish off the the
semi-finals the match will not go into
the blade section because you get even
less points in the blade section so even
if Bobby wins all of the bullets games
he will not be able to catch up that's
if if Magnus wins one more game in the
Rabbids I say I've given one of the
Rapids is drawn with that incredible
resource from Fabi but game 2 goes to
Magnus as he takes the win with the
black pieces so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it we're gonna continue covering
these short games I once again like to
thank Georgiana Branson and not o
muhammad matheus masked man Carl Nelson
and Alexander a : KO for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as
you can check to my previous videos here
by now there will be from the official
random World Championship checking up on
your suggestions as usual so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day